[Musik]
mein name ist mathias entstand ich bin
geschäftsführer anklingt ihm entstand
mein name ist prozent alles klar ich bin
zweiter ausbildungsjahres als
altenpflegerin seit zweier bin ich im
ambulanten pflegedienst mein name ist
hase ich bin krankenpfleger arbeitet
einen ambulanten pflegedienst der circa
105 patienten versorgt aktuell genau ich
bin mit dem auto unterwegs zu den
patienten wo ich zu den nach hause
fahren und die dort versorge vor ort in
der mobilen pflege fahren die
krankenpflege zu den patienten nach
hause
ein wichtiger aufgabenbereich die
grundpflege
hier geht es um die grundversorgung des
patienten der krankenpflege wäscht und
pflegt ihn
er muss viel mit dem patienten sprechen
[Musik]
außerdem gibt es weitere wichtige
aufgaben wie den blutzucker zu messen
[Musik]
oder verbände zu wechseln
alle tätigkeiten die man bei jedem
patienten erledigt hat müssen
dokumentiert werden
auch ein gespräch mit den angehörigen
kann dazu gehören mehr über den beruf
des krankenpflegers erfahrt ihr im
nächsten teil